um he went to mosque I think as a way to
try and calm tensions and put out a
statement it backfired and the mosque I
think in a statement from them it seems
as though those present felt almost they
being used for a bit of a PR opportunity
as opposed to hear their real concerns
um and now you know you're hearing some
on resignation watch now we might not
get to the point of actual resignations
but the fact K has had to meet with some
of his MIM MPS trying and explain his
position I think does point to trouble
ahead for him because the the feeling
amongst these MPS is that he's got the
balance wrong and he is not being
supportive enough of Palestine there is
a balance to be struck and therefore you
have a situation where Muslim voters um
could just not turn out for the labor
party and you could also you know split
parts of your party